hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I just checking I'm just
checking in on you
seeing how you're doing how are you
today huh
are you upset Thursday afternoon to
Thursday Night Football what happened
during the song this time that made
people upset and decided that they were
gonna get all up in arms about their
corner of the [ __ ] world unbelievable
I'm so [ __ ] now I'm gonna be the guy
talking I'm so [ __ ] listening to
people making that thing about what they
want it to be about it's like that's not
what the initial protest was about if
you would like to discuss police
brutality I'm more than willing to
listen to it I don't want to hear your
[ __ ] soliloquy you know all those
people who are like you know want to be
the irreverent like I don't even care I
don't even he yeah of course you don't
care it doesn't [ __ ] what they're
talking about doesn't affect you it's
not about you okay who gives a [ __ ] it's
one moment at the beginning of the game
commenting on something that people are
trying to fix that's all that's all my
biggest complaint about tonight's game
between the Bears and the [ __ ] pair
is they stopped the game because there's
potential of lightning God for [ __ ]
bid somebody gets electrocuted it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable how
important human beings still consider
other human beings I just don't know it
really isn't about that it's like vote
do you think the NFL gives a [ __ ] about
you they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
about you they don't want you to get
electrocuted because then you can't go
out and buy another jersey or another
ticket or NFL Sunday Ticket that's what
they care about and somehow they're
gonna get blamed right because everybody
in the crowd is gonna be like well they
shouldn't know
that God was gonna do that he should
have known what the weather was gonna be
you know there's no more hey [ __ ] you
went outside
you know what's outside lightning and
you went outside and god damnit
lightning found you and that's your own
dumb luck guess what you're gonna have
your own Wikipedia page now you don't
have one now nobody knows who the [ __ ]
you are but you get struck by lightning
somebody's gonna find you on Wikipedia
maybe you won't get your own page you
might be on a page that's just a list of
people struck by lightning in 2017 or in
or in whatever the [ __ ] would call in
this decade it has to be an
extraordinary circumstance to when you
get struck by lightning for you to get
your own Wikipedia page you have to get
struck by lightning and then something
else happens you struck by lightning you
catch on fire and you run into a paper
mache Factory alright with a bunch of
children there who's make-a-wish was
that they could go to a make a [ __ ]
paper mache Factory and then you run in
there and then it all goes up and all
those little kids died then now they
need have to share it with the kids it's
a tough thing it's hard to get struck by
lightning and get your own Wikipedia
page you know you know it's funny if
that actually happened you got struck by
lightning you had a nice afro going you
catches on fire you run into a paper
mache Factory there was a bunch of
make-a-wish kids in there and then they
all [ __ ] died the funniest [ __ ]
thing about all that is how much [ __ ]
your relatives would get you know what I
mean saying oh you know that gag guy
he's one of those Wilson kids yeah you
know his [ __ ] brother get struck by
lightning instead of just dyin laying
there burnin the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
that he is runs into a paper mache
factory and kills a bunch of kids that
were already dying anyways you know and
then everybody treats them like [ __ ]
like you can keep your wits about you
when your heads on fire the bottom line
is is I don't know what happened to
football I don't ever remember it being
stopped because of weather used to be
they play
all kinds of weather right he had the
ice bowl up there in Green Bay
you had that game when all the locusts
descended down on the Kansas City Chiefs
when they played the [ __ ] New York
Titans I'm just making up [ __ ] at this
point I don't know what happened to the
game but now any time it's gonna be a
little bit of crosswind what if it blows
somebody's sunglasses off and goes into
somebody's eye I mean Jesus Christ those
those people that that's Wisconsin
the amount of layers of clothes and
blubber you have to go through after the
lightning strikes them to even like you
know rattle a few fillings loose of the
average person in Wisconsin these are
these are these are wholesome people up
there okay they get that LL Bean catalog
and to those people that is formal where
you understand that you know when you
get married in Wisconsin you can
actually show up you know you know like
everybody you're gonna wear tails with
your tuxedo they asked him if they're
gonna wear those [ __ ] you know those
rubber pants those [ __ ] rhythm with
the suspenders when you go trout fishing
somebody was saying there was some
[ __ ] guy he walked out into the ocean
I don't wanna [ __ ] he was in a river
some sort of water a watery area and he
walked in there and this wave came in
and washed into his [ __ ] pants
welcome tipped him over and he couldn't
get up because the combination of the
weight of his ass and his legs those
rubber pants and all the water in it it
just [ __ ] he drowned I don't know if
that's true that sounds like something a
[ __ ] old lady with Tyson all this
[ __ ] old lady when I was a kid you
know back when you know parents didn't
watch their kids like parenting back in
the day you woke up you gave him [ __ ]
you know the multicolored cereal he
opened the door and they went outside
and they just met other kids and with
you kid brains you figured out what you
were gonna do that day whether it was
this old who lived around the corner and
she used to always tell us all these
crazy [ __ ] stories she had terrible
candy too we could still show up I don't
know why and she's being one-time though
I mean she may lunch I'm you know a
judge guy and he he tried to stomp his
foot down on the brake
to stop so he wouldn't don't prude I
stopped shining she said that his leg
went all the way up into his body and
and it was like six inches shorter for
the rest of his life he walked around
and he couldn't go you know I used to
come home and I repeat the stories to my
mother right I'd be like mom you know
one time it was a guy his way what
happened to his body and she one day she
just finally I think was listening to me
she just looked at me she goes who told
you that now it's like oh the lady down
the street she goes don't listen to her
she's crazy I don't know what my mother
talk like that I needed to do a
different voice she doesn't smoke I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about but what would you expect from
someone who forgot it was Thursday
that's how awesome my life is I forgot
it was Thursday now sometimes you can
forget it's Thursday because your life
is [ __ ] terrible right your onda
right you're on a [ __ ] bender or
you're you're like I don't know what
your [ __ ] I don't know you [ __ ]
you're a political prisoner you forget
what date is you're in Shawshank all
right sometimes you fight them off
sometimes you don't you're marking off
the days you got Rita Hayworth on the
wall you don't know what [ __ ] date is
not even if you're Andy Dufresne and
you're good with numbers you lose track
and the only other people that lose
track of that are people who work for
themselves which I don't I work for
Netflix now I guess I don't I just you
know after a while you just said what
[ __ ] day is it I don't know another
day living the dream did anyways okay
football Sundays coming up what pop-up
all Beauty booed him I'm gonna start
doing my gambling pick of the week my
gambling pick of the week all right
I'm guaranteeing you that if you gamble
on this game money is gonna change hands
either out of your pocket or into your
pocket or it might be a push I'm
guaranteeing that he called me up at
1-800 freckles five five five
the Giants getting three and Tampa Bay
the Giants the O and three Giants
everybody looking at him like they're
washed up forgetting that Eli Manning
has won two
Super Bowls against the reigning Super
Bowl champions they beat Bill Belichick
two times guys got two rings you know
he's got he's got two rings he's got no
respect and he's got half an offensive
line but I think this week they're
getting three they're underdogs they did
fine fine against Philly last week they
came back label gives a [ __ ] they still
scored twenty some points I didn't
really pay attention right and then they
lost on a 61 [ __ ] year right some
[ __ ] dude from 90210 came walking in
right he just [ __ ] kicked the goddamn
thing like the end of a Hollywood movie
all right
ain't gonna happen they're gonna go down
to Tampa okay first of all nobody
respects the Tampa Bay Buccaneers you
know why cuz they have a giant Pirates
of the Caribbean ship inside their
Stadium I don't know what they're trying
to do I don't understand how the Oakland
Raiders okay who have like a pirate on
the side of the helmet are able to
achieve the baddest baddest [ __ ]
uniform in all the sports as far as I'm
concerned they when they move to Vegas
and they have the white home jerseys
they better go back to the silver
numbers or my name isn't Billy fat tits
alright Tampa Bay Buccaneers I don't
underst is what is a Buccaneer exactly
okay let's look this up because judging
by their colors I feel like it's more
like the musical-theater
sort of pirate it's much more let's just
go out and have an adventure rather than
raping and pillaging what do we got here
all right in the [ __ ] Buccaneers lost
last week 34 to 17 so they're coming off
a big loss that's always a concern what
the [ __ ] is a Buccaneer Buccaneer
alright Buccaneers were a kind okay a
private er or pirate
what's a private er privateer a
privateer was a private person also they
keep to themselves well that's not
really good in a team sport is it or
ship that in gay
used in maritime warfare okay under a
commission of war all right well it did
it very officially all right
particularly to the Caribbean Sea yet
Pirates of the Caribbean that's right
originally the name applied to the
landless hunters of wild boars and
cattle in the largely uninhabited areas
of Tortuga and Hispaniola the meat cut
they smoked over a slow fire where the
what are we talking about some about
jerk meat or jerky why should we fear
these people you know what this is just
a whole bunch of reading that I don't
want to do it when caught by anti pirate
English authorities seven or eight you
know what I need to do what's there
between a pirate in a Buccaneer what's
the difference what's the difference
between a raid in Oakland read in a
Buccaneer I would say about thirty
pounds
I've been why never been to the Tampa
stadium might be there in a few weeks oh
okay
Buccaneer verse radar what's the
difference this is why you got to love
the internet I'm not saying they have a
right answer but they always have an
answer what's the difference
Buccaneer is a synonym of Raider as
nouns the difference between a Buccaneer
and a Raider is that Buccaneer is is
nautical any of a group of seamen jizz
no see men who cruised on their own
account on the Spanish mane and in the
Pacific in the 17th century similar to
pirates but did not prey on ships of
their own nation while a raid is one who
gages engages in a raid : semicolon a
plunderer well what the [ __ ] is a raid
and what is a plunderer
see this is to see what you do you
[ __ ] plunderer
the plunderer is a fictional character
so they they don't even exist and I
don't want this [ __ ] that was
actually a superhero daredevil fought
the plunderer plunderer come on man come
on give me something give me something
here yet [ __ ] plunder Wikipedia is just
such a one trick pony sometimes I just
keep guiding you back to the same
[ __ ] to plunder the public treasury
to take run freely as pillage yeah okay
all right you know I I don't even give a
[ __ ] anymore how about that all I know
is whoever [ __ ] drew the Raiders logo
did not draw the Buccaneers logo that
first one at least unless he was a rate
of fent it was like these for these
[ __ ] guys saying that kind of like us
we already took this name
let me see Tampa Bay [ __ ] ears this
would be like a porno logo what do we
got here sort of a pirate oh yeah they
you know they kind of ripped off they're
trying to rip off the old [ __ ] trying
to rip off the Raiders here well let's
see they're [ __ ] original the
original logo was just like I think was
Tom Selleck I don't know what it was
yeah really Tom Selleck he's sort of
winking at you tiniest of knives in his
[ __ ] mouth there's the one I remember
right there
the creamsicle yeah I don't what that
was he look like a three musketeer he
look like a good guy I think that that
was the problem was there a point to any
of that I don't think it was um anyways
this is one of the this is one of the
greatest times of the year in the United
States Sports and who's kidding our
sports are the best if you don't believe
it if you don't believe our athletes are
the best I'm telling you you need to
watch the Olympics okay all of our white
athletes dominating all of those games
well maybe we do well in the Winter
Olympics don't we now we don't we lose
to the [ __ ] Canadians we beat the
Canadians in like the dead juniors we
always beat them because anybody like
our age has already made it up
to the [ __ ] NHL you know but you got
to give those Canadians something hockey
they got you they ate that you got to
let him have hockey even though the
Russians had kind of slowly taken it
away from him a lot of European players
the game is slowly being taken away from
their sticky syrup two fingers up there
okay we all understand this all right
and they're gonna hang on for dear
[ __ ] life because if Canada
god forbid ever was to lose hockey what
would they be left with huh what would
they be left with that that shuffleboard
on ice that they play what do they call
it what they call that what the [ __ ] is
it you slide you just let that [ __ ] go
all right that big sort of a wheel isn't
it it's a rim can also a rim off of a
Jeep that they turn into a giant hockey
puck that's what it's just an obese
hockey puck what the [ __ ] do you call it
curling I don't know why they call it
curly there's no hooking there's nothing
like that you don't [ __ ] I have no
idea um anyway so you have playoff
baseball's coming up hoop is gonna start
hockey's gonna start college and pro
football's going the CFL is getting
close to the Grey Cup all right I mean
just what else could you want
okay the Formula One and MotoGP are
gonna be wrapping up here in the next 40
days misses exciting [ __ ] times let's
check out the baseball standings shall
we everybody what do we got here is
Boston Red Sox hanging on for dear life
three games ahead of the New York they
New York Yankees Tampa Bay Devil Rays
soon to be Montreal Expos spoiler alert
I'm gonna tell you guys that story must
have told this story the time I went to
the Montreal Expos game by myself I was
doing this gig in upstate New York and
you know I was trying to go to all the
[ __ ] stadiums so I was like alright
well you know let's see this Montreal
yeah they got a
can game say a game the next day so I
went up I did this gig I think I did the
Lake Ontario Playhouse I know I've told
this story before but maybe I got a few
listeners maybe from something from
Kenya is listening maybe somebody from
romaine yeah anyways so there was a game
the next day so I ended up trying to
cross the border into Canada this is pre
9/11 by the way in a very weird spot by
myself so I get stopped at the border
the guy tell you guy asked me he's like
whoa what are you doing there fella
it's Canadian dude and I said I'm going
to an expose game now the expose had
lost probably about I don't know like a
hundred and twenty games at that point
during the season and he goes off you
meeting some friends up there and I was
like nope
going by myself he was like oh hey pal
would you mind I'll pull it over right
there for a second so he asked me pull
over and like two more these [ __ ]
guys come out and they start ripping
apart my car and they send me inside and
I'm like what the fight is some sort of
random drug search and I'm just sitting
there watching them and they're ripping
it apart and ripping it apart and then
it [ __ ] suddenly [ __ ] dawns on me
like what kind of a [ __ ] loser I mean
I was like two hours away I was gonna
drive two hours out of my way to go up
there to go to a Montreal Expos game by
myself this guy could not fathom that
any human being even one that looked
like me would have that much of a
pathetic moment in their life he was
convinced that was some sort of drug
mule or whatever I guess drug mules is
that when you have it up your ass but I
never checked my ass they just checked
the [ __ ] car so it suddenly dawned on
me that they thought there was no way
that I was that pathetic but I knew the
real answer was yes I was that pathetic
so it just struck me as funny and I
started laughing and I couldn't stop and
I remember the cop looking over at me
and he saw me laughing and I think he
thought I was laughing like he couldn't
find the drugs so they were out there
for like a [ __ ] half-hour and then
once I knew that they thought I had
drugs then I was just kind of acting
like a dick and I had a shit-eating grin
on my face as I came walking up smile
and they well the guy was getting mad
like I was smiling like he didn't find
it or whatever and then I went up there
I went up there and this [ __ ] French
[ __ ] acted like he didn't understand
what I said when I asked him to take my
picture because I don't have anybody
take my picture because I was by myself
had one of those disposable cameras that
the story just keeps getting worse and
worse and when I called him a [ __ ] he
laughed and walked away so anyways I was
sitting out in like [ __ ] left-field
and it was such an old stadium I don't
know one just under budget I think
that's socialism up there you know they
just don't step on the poor the way we
do up here out in the outfield your seat
only had one armrest
that's what I remember Eva on the left
or on the right I can't remember what
and I was sitting out there and all the
fans were not paying attention in the
game the fans that showed up and they
were just singing Olleh Olleh Olleh
Olleh that soccer [ __ ] song and I was
watching I swear to God I saw this guy
and I'm like I watch this guy steal home
plate and I'm way out in left field so I
jumped up I was like yeah when he stole
home plate and nobody else jumped up
with me and it was really quiet in in
the stadium so then I was like oh [ __ ]
maybe that was something else
maybe I don't know maybe was a passed
ball maybe there was a balk I didn't
know what so I [ __ ] sat back down I
felt stupid because everyone was looking
at me and then later on that night I was
back at the [ __ ] hotel and I was
watching TSN that's their ESPN up there
and they're like oh here's something you
don't see every day and they showed a
guy stealing home plate it was like yeah
that's my expose story not riveting but
not boring alright then you got the
Cleveland Indians crushing it crushing
it 120 twinners sep 22 in a row I feel
like they've won like maybe what like
like 25 or their last 30 not 27 they're
in and who else the Houston Astros oh
wow well look who's finally in the
American League finally put on your
big-boy pants and you can stop playing
hit and run and get yourself nice and
roided-up and try to hit it over the
fence huh
the Washington Senators in first place I
didn't [ __ ] know that the Cubs
looking to repeat the Dodgers I went to
the Dodger game last night they went
[ __ ] 10 to nothing I had a great time
we sat right down on the field like
terrifyingly close like I tried to make
sure I watched every goddamn pitch and
you know I'm not boozing so you know
that's also scary if you boozing you
know you're all relaxed your heads like
[ __ ] foam rubber you know what I mean
it she just bounces off it what happened
well you know you don't know you order
another [ __ ] round right but I'm
stone sober sitting there so I actually
realize what the [ __ ] had happened so I
was staying right on it what a great
Stadium that is just a great stay in
great fans out there you know what I
mean as long as you don't wear a
different colored jersey and you don't
sit out in the bleachers you know what I
mean
as long as you're not with your kids
it's a great stadium it's great so long
as you're rooting for the Dodgers it's a
wonderful time and I went there had a
pretty good time I had a great time I
should say I meant to say I ate pretty
good ate pretty good I got a little off
my dial-up diet when I was in [ __ ]
Toronto so I think my calf is healed up
we're gonna try hit the elliptical
tomorrow hey guess what old freckles old
freckles is playing the Monte Carlo
tomorrow in Las Vegas it's gonna be
great bunch of people from afters four
family are coming out or a bunch of
writers are gonna be at the show so I'm
hoping I'm gonna have a good one I'm
very excited to play that one that's the
one from an out River Phoenix what was
the name of that [ __ ] movie Ocean's
thirteen or 12:15 whatever the [ __ ] it
was called where everybody's all those
good-looking fellas stood out there
right looking at the the oh is it though
the fountains the function of you guys
saw that movie yeah that's that casino
playing that one I've always wanted to
play that one how we start was the
cleanest and classiest looking one at
least from the outside you walk into the
things they all look the same but anyway
so let's let's get on to the let's get
on to the what do we got here a little
bit of advertising here Oh draftkings
everybody
draftkings okay and I said ice what did
I say Giants get in three Giants getting
three on three ready
all right draft kings football season
has begun what are you a political
prisoner you don't realize that but it's
not too late to get closer to the game
you love with draft kings one-week
fantasy football this draft kings is
hosting a 100 thousand sorry this is
capitols ice cream capitals thanks give
to have a capital I'm gonna scream
dollar contest that is totally to enter
when draft with draft kings there are
many ways to play but only one way to
win choose between public contests butts
with big cash prizes or private contests
where you can compete against a group of
your friends no saying means stuff in
here let's make this a safe place
draftkings also has a beginner in cat oh
you're a big boy degenerate and casual
contest will you play against people of
a similar skill level and you'll never
burn up the waiver wire trying to
replace injured players because you get
to pick a new team every goddamn week
that's the beauty of one-week fantasy
and draftkings so get to grab games.com
now now and use promo code bar to play
in draft kings free contest with a
dollars in prizes a Sunday
that's promo code per to compete for
your share of a one hundred thousand
hundred thousand dollars in prizes the
contest is totally free to enter why
wouldn't you try draftkings the game
inside the game eligibility restrictions
applies see draft kings coms for details
all right oh oh look who's back but do
me undies me undies taken a [ __ ] need
to do to be on DS b undies from sea to
[ __ ] shine in see white people say it
means this black people say
that but we all could wear a nice
comfortable underwear with the guts
hanging over up all bags me undies you
want to look good in your underwear and
be comfortable right but that perfect
balance is hard to find every day one of
your balls is hanging a little bit more
to the right than the left
well don't sacrifice style or comfort or
your nuts check out me undies come and
find the best pair of underwear in the
world talk about why me undies is the
best underwear you will ever own I'll
tell you why because they're the only
underwear company paying me right now me
undies has an exclusive offer just for
my listeners and probably a thousand
other podcasts get 20% off your first
pair and free shipping and me undies is
so sure you will love their underwear
they even offer a 100% satisfaction
guarantee you order a pair and if you
don't love your first pair get a full
refund this is a no-brainer to try 20%
off free shipping on our percent
satisfaction guarantee what are you
waiting for huh
to get 20% off and free shipping and
their 100% satisfaction guarantee and
get the best price and softest underwear
you will ever own go to me undies
dot-com slash burn this is a limited
time offer that I've been reading for
like [ __ ] a year now so what are you
waiting for
start wearing the best underwear of your
life don't you think your clam and nuts
deserve it it's changed my life
evidently it's time to let me undies
change yours go to me undies dot-com
slash bar right now all right last one
lastly but not leastly Legal Zoom
everybody you know when you run your own
business you know that time equals money
it's not just ten Holt's saying it's a
[ __ ] fact so why waste your valuable
time dealing with issues that LegalZoom
can help you with huh
you may already know that over two
million people have used Legal Zoom to
they're businesses but LegalZoom
services do not end there running a
business comes with taxes contracts
hiring employees changing the filter in
the air-conditioning system basically a
lot of fine print that's why LegalZoom
built a network of independent attorneys
licensed in all 50 states they can
provide the advice you need to get
through the daily grind of running your
business and you don't have to worry
about billable hours since Legal Zoom is
not a law firm instead you can count on
upfront pricing and clarity invest your
time and money in growing your business
and let LegalZoom help out with the
legal stuff for special savings be sure
to enter promo code bur be URR in the
referral box at checkout that's promo
code bar for a special savings only at
legalzoom.com legalzoom.com
alright there you go there you go
somebody asked me to do a benefit today
for pay
doh Rico those poor bastards are still
without power door you know after you
have to get hit by that hurricane and
everybody's over here talking about
somebody taking Annie
I actually think taking Annie is more
respectful than standing up isn't it
Christ the guys on his [ __ ] knees so
hopefully I'll be able to do that
hopefully people stops focusing on the
song and start focusing more on the
heroin epidemic right oh I'm on my
soapbox the fact that we're feeding cows
to other cows and cutting the beaks off
of birds that are walking around doing
face plants because it breasts are too
[ __ ] big you know you can't even give
him a beak to [ __ ] land on that's
like that maxsa gets smart episode where
they put him in the gurney and they
strapped him in and there was only one
of those [ __ ] rotary doors they stood
him up you ever seen that one they push
them through and he does the [ __ ]
faceplant
oh that bit killed me I loved it back in
the day can you tell I'm a huge me TV
fan I've been taping the Twilight zones
over there and not only is the Twilight
Zone great what's awesome about it is
afterwards I then get to do my favorite
thing is Google to see how much of the
cast is dead and I was surprised I
watched the one that was the witched
pool the both of the little kids are
still alive they're in their 60s the
mother is still alive still alive and
kicking like 89 years old
however the dad [ __ ] dropped like
less than ten years later in the early
seventies had a heart attack you know
what I mean no it was a big thing back
in the day guys died of heart attacks
and women died of accidental overdose
overdose asyou know because anytime they
got air-quote hysterical they would give
them black beauties and all the guys get
a Holley itself you know they get
slapped around in the doctor's office
and then you know to make sure the
swelling went down they would give him
these relaxer fires for their cheeks in
their in their in the rest of their body
something like that I forget how it goes
but that's what I do like I watch Hawaii
five-o just about every night and the
other night they had this episode called
to hell with Babe Ruth and that was a
big rumor write that back in the day
back
the day when I was young I'm not a kid
anymore they used to hello come on in
turn the knob oh I thought you were
coming in so back in the day oh it's the
lovely Nia hi hi why'd you come in then
oh yeah what are you ordering rice and
that sort of thing
lament right all right well I already
ate for the evening I had another
tabbouleh salad with chicken yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's fascinating so I'm gonna
go order dinner
hi I think I've been seeing you in so
long we were supposed to have a date
night tonight yeah and you blew me off
you blew me off Papa Papa Papa Papa all
right to hell with Babe Ruth okay this
is alleged allegedly huh yes you're
being dismissed
you know what nyet you're fired now um I
um at the end of the podcast you know I
was telling them about that to hell with
Babe Ruth thing
remember the y5o I was showing you when
they had the white guy playing the
Japanese guy with and but then the lady
he was with was I don't know if she was
Japanese but she was definitely Asian
and so she's got to sit there and look
at him with this [ __ ] white guy
stupid thing and then they put this
awful makeup around his eyes this is 50
years ago yeah I think I don't know what
to say about I'm just just bringing it
up that was terrible it was 50 I was
half a century ago okay nokey dokey
so anyways allegedly during the World
War two when the Japanese soldiers would
do a buns I charge which is [ __ ] a
suicidal
I guess whatever like Japan was not
[ __ ] around
there was no quitting okay there was no
everybody gets a ribbon alright
they were just if you [ __ ] there was
no surrendering to your [ __ ] enemy so
during those Banzai charges allegedly I
don't know if this is propaganda they
would yell either to hell with Babe Ruth
or [ __ ] Babe Ruth is what they would
yell right so Babe Ruth got wind of it
and there's a quote in the New York
Times I gotta get this right I don't
want to misquote the Sultan of Swat the
only man who ever had a ballpark built
around his [ __ ] abilities let me see
if I could find this you can't I can't
find it he basically said he goes any
[ __ ] that says that I hope they should I
hope it gets shot he goes and while
we're at it he goes to hell with all the
Japs that was written in the New York
Times you know you could never do that
in 1969 by the time that episode of
Hawaii five-o came out but what you
could do was have a white guy with the
worst makeup ever or I'm gonna [ __ ]
I'm gonna post the picture I got to post
the picture I always I don't know if I'm
gonna do it either I just want to make
sure I just got a picture of John Daly
you know [ __ ] in his sweat pants
[ __ ] making a chocolate shake for
himself in a glass that had the Arkansas
Razorback thing on it is there anything
about John Daly that isn't awesome
anything so anyways I was watching this
episode and this guy I'm watching the
whole time going that guy is not
Japanese what the [ __ ] I was looking
there's something wrong with his eyes or
whatever I finally looked up the actor
and I don't know what he was he was
first-generation something rather but it
was not to you you should just see
theses faces whole face is [ __ ] white
features then he had this like he was
sort of squinting his eyes the whole I
was just was horrific felt bad for the
lady across him I can't imagine what she
said when she came home with his funny
kid it didn't even look good
ah so anyways I guess what I'm saying
it's about time we make a world for to
movie you know we actually have Japanese
people play Japanese soldiers can we at
least do that has it been done I don't
know I watch sports ok and there is no
fact-checking whatsoever when it comes
to when it comes to the podcast guys
I ordered the greatest [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
whiskey glass you will ever own in your
[ __ ] life and it's so awesome that I
know when you see it you're gonna want
it
alright this guy's got a small operation
so I'm not gonna tell you who it is
until I order some more and get my order
in and then I'm gonna let you know on
Monday Monday Monday I can't be that
much of a [ __ ] this is a great gift if
you have a [ __ ] person who loves
hangers [ __ ] whiskey glasses ever
there's this guy he exists does this
sound right this sounds kind of
perverted he blows his own glass it was
a bad time to pause on it huh he blows
his own
three-two-one glass Nate Cartman
na te Co TT er ma n Nate Cartman calm
can make you all kinds of things
I actually [ __ ] up my order I called
the number up and he the guy just picked
up he's like Hello I'm like yes Nate
there's I guess night now Mike and dude
I ordered the riot put in an order for
eight glasses I ordered the wrong ones
I wanted the ones with the square cube
but he goes oh yeah I saw that
alright I'll take care of that how'd you
hear about it I was just looking up
whiskey glasses is what the guy does
alright for all you guys out there you
drink the top-shelf booze alright you're
a self-made man or you were born
to it give a [ __ ] right you got you a
woman in line no and you got it you got
a top-shelf bottle of booze and you
respect the booze you respect the artist
artists who [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
did whatever he did to make it his mute
and his in his in his tasty God's gonna
make me go right off the wagon and it's
tasty as it is in and you you but you
wanted Colt you know so there's all
these different things there's these
giant ice cubes you can put in there
these big square ones but eventually
towards the end you know the water is
gonna start leaking into the booze you
getting me talking tap water here okay
like beavers [ __ ] in this stuff is
mixing in with your goddamn boobs you
can't have that the aroma of duck feet
is it's coming into your pristine
firewater here right so then they also
have they got these metal cubes or
whatever but then you know no matter
what there's gonna be some sort of
metallic maybe blah blah blah blah blah
this guy Nate all hail Nate he makes a
whiskey glass and then he makes a a
square glass [ __ ] ice cube and
marries that to the clay becomes part of
the glass then you take the whole
[ __ ] glass you stick it in the fridge
the freezer whatever and then
everything's cold okay and then you pour
it in there okay the booze has nowhere
to hide
it's surrounded on all sides by nice
chilled frigid glass but none of it
leaks into the booze so you can drink it
neat and have it ice-cold you can have
your [ __ ] cake and eat it with these
glasses I cannot say enough about them I
absolutely love these [ __ ] glasses
and I haven't even used them yet they
got a little weight to them too so if
you limp wristed it you know if you yeah
I don't know if you you know back in the
day you get an old rollerblading injury
and you broke both your wrists these
might not be for you okay but I [ __ ]
love these glasses did you and then and
their coolest [ __ ] Nate Cartman with a/c
all right that's it enjoy the music and
we got another half hour [ __ ] coming up
stay afternoon just before Monday
morning podcasts and a Thursday gone by
you know possibly earlier this year
maybe it was from three years ago I
don't [ __ ] know I don't pick them all
right have a great weekend you [ __ ]
I'll see you in Vegas and that's it
right yeah
[Music]
this way oh you know I didn't even get
to that [ __ ] you see that reporter
that died let me get to it where the
hell is that story here this writer for
Rolling Stone which I have a
subscription to one of the magazine's
few magazines that I actually read every
episode every installment Michael
Hastings he had a horrible death he
[ __ ] was going down I believe it was
Highland just south of Melrose his
Mercedes was travelling at ridiculous
speeds he hit a [ __ ] tree and the
whole thing exploded bursted into flames
and they had to identify him by his
dental records and allegedly this guy
knew I guess he broke some [ __ ]
article in Rolling Stone where he was
over in Afghanistan talking to some
higher-ups in the military and they were
saying some [ __ ] that they thought was
off the record and he put it all in the
article and there's people conspiracy
there is trying to say that his car was
cyber attacked now I'm not even gonna
get into that but to how [ __ ] up is
the world getting if like that's
actually something that somebody could
do I'm not saying whether it was done by
this guy or not I have no [ __ ] idea
he might have been hammered I have no
idea I have no [ __ ] clue I don't know
anything about it but I'm just saying
that the fact that somebody could hack
into your computer and cause your car to
speed up and there's nothing you can you
can't shut the car off this is why I
don't know that I don't believe that
it's just like as evil as that is we got
to eliminate this guy isn't there a
zillion other ways to kill him without
doing that like what if he slammed into
like a [ __ ] minivan with the you know
a married couple and their three four
kids
you know there's got to be you know
can't they just spray some mist on them
you know just walk up to him in the mall
like hi sir would you like to try this
fragrance you just spray it on him and
then the guy like you know ten minutes
later he's trying on some slacks he just
keels over he can't just do it that way
but anyways is this true is can they
actually do that [ __ ] and this makes me
feel glad that you know half my time out
here I drive around in a classic car
you know because not like I'm any sort
of a threat but what I'm saying is if
that if I just would think if you had
the ability to do that some [ __ ]
nerds would just do it just to do it cuz
it would be funny just speed you up for
a second then slow you down just to
freak you out you know like do you
remember back in the day when this is
like pre-internet fun what you would do
is you take your garage door opener
right and you would drive around the
neighborhood and he'd pointed at every
garage until you found somebody that had
the same one as you and back in the day
they just had a like it wasn't
sophisticated so not only yours opened
not only yours it opened the other ones
too so you'd you'd eventually find
somebody that had the same garage door
brand as you and you could open and
close their garage so at least you
couldn't my [ __ ] neighborhood so you
just find you just drive one person nuts
you just drive by and you just [ __ ]
everyone so why would just open it and I
don't know why we would do it we were
[ __ ] but so using that if you could
[ __ ] do that with cars wouldn't
wouldn't like these people like you know
hack into steal like credit card numbers
and [ __ ] I mean wouldn't that be
somebody just doing that just to do it
like you're bored it was just that was
this the dumbest part of the podcast
everybody did I stick the landing
starting off with ignorance and then
well why wouldn't they well well [ __ ]
you know what it the reality if I have a
book of commercial I'm gonna be you know
that commercial with the adults it's
there with all the kids and they go you
know what would you what would you do if
you had a zillion dollars and the kids
like an island made out of candy yeah we
could have hot fudge you've waterfalls
and [ __ ] I would be sitting there right
with except it wouldn't be like the
basketball one where they were like
making fun of the fact like I would be
like you don't say I'm saying I'm a
[ __ ] buddy
[Music]
alright for the birds hey Bill I got
these two parakeets my problem is that
these little dudes don't like me I've
tried whistling petting them I don't
know you can pet a bird and squirting
them with water
do they like water I'm guessing that
that's a good thing parakeets like water
I know why don't we ask the [ __ ]
Jimmy's guy to write a [ __ ] 9 pages
on it
I love how upset with that guy cuz he
actually did the research as opposed to
me who would like oh yeah I overheard
this in a bar so anyways this guy's
petting his birds he's [ __ ] getting
them with the water hose he's whistling
Adam whoo all to no avail I know there
are only birds but I feel they hold a
deep resentment towards me where you
clip their wings and you stuck him in a
cage how would you feel somebody cut
your [ __ ] nuts off came by started
whistling at you and throwing water at
you you know I got an idea why don't you
leave him alone don't you open the cage
right why don't you take them to one of
those Kardashian doctors and get a
little Botox in their [ __ ] wings and
let them fly away would that be annoying
to you if you were in a cage your arms
cut off at the [ __ ] elbows and
somebody came up and rather than whistle
and they started speaking English are
you speaking English at you because I
think it's because I yelled at them well
here we go
because I think they resent me because I
yelled at them what did you what what
were they doing
I said no basically I had to scold them
for pooping in their water dish but I
had their best interest in mind do you
understand how [ __ ] insane you are
that you feel like you can talk to a
bird you know why don't you like not
stick the water dish you know underwear
that was it underneath the swing or what
I would do is I just get a bigger cage
I'd get a bigger [ __ ] cage I put the
water in the center that isn't near any
of those trapeze bars and hopefully they
won't be at the top of the cage and
still [ __ ] down on it or I would accept
the fact that it's a bird in a cage and
that it's you know basically anything at
the bottom of the cage might as well be
the city of Dresden right I would just
take that as part of it I wouldn't yell
at the birds but anyways this guy he had
to scold them for pooping in their water
but I had their best interest in mind I
heard if they drink contaminated water
it can cause a disease that makes all
their feathers fall off well you could
also read up on it as opposed to me who
just repeats shits that they hear he
goes I do a lot for those little guys
but putting jackets on nude parakeets
isn't one of them even if I wanted to I
couldn't they don't even let me pet them
let alone dress them dude you're not a
bird guy you should have got a dog he
goes when I originally bought them I
imagined I would have one parakeet on
each shoulder while hanging out around
my house but instead whenever I
approached the cage they freeze in
horror every time they do that I can't
help but remember my brother's face when
he fell through the ice we had to pull
him out I thought maybe if I bought them
more toys they would that would somehow
help dude Birds motivation isn't more
toys their motivation is you not have an
energy like I'm gonna [ __ ] twist your
head off dude their wings are clipped so
they can't escape you got them stuck in
a cage they're terrified and you yelled
at them I would say more than on one
occasion you yelled at them alright you
need to [ __ ] relax all right listen
to this would you would you want to be
like your job to be in a cage all day
you know and then some you know I don't
know some giant comes home and puts you
on its [ __ ] shoulders and your whole
job is to enhance the Giant's [ __ ]
life you don't even have a little bit of
empathy for the [ __ ] birds what I
would do is I would just have our
totally relaxed energy and hope that
they forget that you screamed at them
treat them nicely don't try to pass
just don't [ __ ] with them every time you
come over they'll graduate be like oh
this is the guy who feeds us this cow
brings water this guy's on our side you
know as opposed to the mixed messages
that you send them yeah birds don't give
a [ __ ] about toys you know do they I
don't think they do we said I bought to
have a new toy every Friday on my way
home from work and there's a ridiculous
amount of toys in the cage and here's
the kicker they haven't played with the
single one not once what do you look at
the birds outside they're not out if you
leave your toddler's toys outside they
don't go oh good they left and then they
go down they start playing on it's
[ __ ] tricycle he goes they just stare
at me
I took them to the vet but he spent more
time looking at his phone than the birds
anyways any advice would be greatly
appreciated
I think you should find a bird lover sir
and give the birds away and then I don't
know I think you should get your temper
in check and before and before you do
that yeah get your temper in check and
then if you want to get a dog it seems
like you want more interaction with the
pet most people get birds because they
can have an interaction with an animal
but they don't have to walk it down the
street and it's very a lot less
interaction with them you seem like you
want a bird to act like a dog slash a
little kid like a daddy's home I bought
you a fire engine work you know somehow
you want the bird to do that yeah please
stop yelling at your birds alright they
can't help if they [ __ ] in the water you
know the birds they're not supposed to
be in cages they fly around and they
[ __ ] as they fly they [ __ ] when they're
on branches when they have to go they go
they don't have any stress they don't
have any shame and there's water all
over the place so now they got them in
this [ __ ] cage with little confined
area water you know what what are they
supposed to do well what do I know about
the restaurant business
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday September 28th 2009 my voice is a
little raspy this morning because I did
a lot of shows this weekend getting
ready for my my next hour special that's
going to tape in December and somebody
actually sent me an email questioning
when where and all that type of [ __ ] and
we're still solidifying all of that so
the second I know I will let you guys
know the chosen 14 listeners that I have
on my podcast which I know at this point
is more than that you know I've checked
out some Google Trends and saw that I
think I'm up to about 17 I have no
[ __ ] idea how many people listen to
this and I could give a [ __ ] alright
that's it I mean I give a [ __ ] I want
people to [ __ ] listen but I don't do
this thing - I don't know I know it's
weird I don't [ __ ] hype this thing
really if you find it you find it you
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright so this is my deal
it's Monday and I'm still in Addison
Texas why do you ask why Bill I thought
Monday was the day you went back to
Hollywood and tried to pursue your
dreams of getting into a [ __ ] movie
here or there
well I'm hanging around one more day
because I'm going to the Cowboys game
tonight on Monday Night Football Cowboys
playing the [ __ ] they playing at
Carolina Panthers I'm kind of out of
sorts oh you know something you're not
getting this podcast everybody you
listen to it right now and it's Tuesday
morning and I'll tell you why you didn't
[ __ ] get it is because these [ __ ]
[ __ ] at the hotel are raping me on
the internet and you know I feel about
corporations I don't [ __ ] like them
this is what these [ __ ] [ __ ] do
right you sign up for the internet it's
13 bucks a day at this [ __ ] hotel
right 13 bucks a day that's already
ridiculous all right but I'm on the road
you know what
I'm making some money here I'm doing all
right and I need to [ __ ] I need the
Internet I lost my [ __ ] blackberry so
I'm like I [ __ ] it I'll pay it
so I sign up for this [ __ ] at about 10
o'clock at night after I had flown in
Wednesday night and the next you know
the next day you know I signed up it for
for a [ __ ] day 24 hours right my
world a day is 24 hours all right so I
you know I wake up the next day I do the
morning radio I hide my shows I have a
great [ __ ] time I come back in the
afternoon when I say you know what I
think I'll go on that that that
newfangled Internet that the kids are
talking about right I go to go on the
internet lo and behold I'm not on the
[ __ ] internet anymore and I'm like
wait a minute even though I went to
[ __ ] summer school just about every
goddamn year in high school because of
math I know how to [ __ ] add alright
was that algebra [ __ ] in geometry and
algebra 2 and trig and all that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] me up because you know I'm
not into shapes the second they started
drawing those triangles on the Politis
didn't give a [ __ ] it's just like really
you know there's certain things in life
you just [ __ ] know you're never gonna
use alright now I know that you know a
lot of the things I'm probably [ __ ]
sitting in this room right now because
of geometry look at all these shapes
when I look around the wind they'll
[ __ ] look out the window that's a
rectangle my doors are rectangle
there's a [ __ ] triangle well that's a
right angle on the doorway hell there's
four of them right is that geometry I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is is there
an isosceles triangle over by my phone I
don't [ __ ] know all right but I know
you know what I mean
you just [ __ ] know some stuff you
know you're just gonna suck it so
whatever bill get on come gonna stay on
[ __ ] track here right so anyways so
basically it was it had been about 14
hours since I signed up for the internet
and all of a sudden I'm not on the
[ __ ] internet again so I go back
online to figure out what's going on and
right out
you'd sign you sign up for 24 hours it
says in small print in parenthesis that
it expires every day at noontime so
basically I didn't sign up for 24 hours
what I signed up for was yeah 14 hours
I paid $13 for 14 hours of [ __ ]
Internet eight of which I was sleeping
ok so yeah they [ __ ] rape me they
came up with a new little [ __ ] [ __ ]
new little you know they just sit around
like this these [ __ ] money-grubbing
little [ __ ] to figure out some little
[ __ ] way you know that they can just
somehow squeeze they I mean I'm sure if
I sat down and try to figure out the map
the math of like when people arrive in a
hotel and when they usually check out
like how having it expire everyday it
[ __ ] noon gets them a little bit more
money you know so they can make their
yachts just a little bit bigger so you
know what it was a usual [ __ ] what do I
do I call the front desk right and who
do I get do I get the head of the
corporation that runs this internet scam
of course not I get some [ __ ] 25 year
old person who [ __ ] majored in
transportation or [ __ ] I don't know
hotel management and now has no [ __ ]
benefits and is working the front desk
and I'm pissed
so I say to him I say hey that chippy
this is Bill burr calling in [ __ ]
room one zero one eight nine err I don't
know what just wanted to get military
there alpha red Niner 68 cross power
trap door whatever the [ __ ] you call it
anyway so I [ __ ] call this guy up and
I go look I just signed up for a [ __ ]
day and now it shuts off at noon and the
guy goes yeah and I we don't have
anything to do with that here at the
hotel the internet is a complete
separate entity so even though you're in
the hotel and you're currently having
their dick firmly in your ass we don't
have any responsibility on that if you'd
like to come if you know I can [ __ ]
complain I have to go back
on the [ __ ] Internet and pay another
13 [ __ ] dollars to complain to these
[ __ ] so you know what [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what
you dumb [ __ ] you could have got 80
bucks out of me I was willing to pay 13
a day even though that was a total
[ __ ] ripoff because you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] II attitude now you only
get 13 bucks out of me
all right I don't understand why they do
that why they just I mean do people just
give in to it trying to find the name of
these [ __ ] what is it I CH or
something like that I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is what gives a [ __ ] right
I'm just having one of these [ __ ]
weeks so now I don't have any questions
because I haven't been on the [ __ ]
Internet this week so I'm just basically
gonna have to wing this podcast but
fortunately I have plenty of stories for
my wonderful stay out here in Addison
Texas here's one for you I'm gonna be on
the road for the next three weeks so
that's obviously putting a strain on my
relationship okay so I'm thinking maybe
I'll do something nice for the funk in
two days I'm gonna be home over the next
three weeks and I'm a big fan of the
Corvette everybody
do you like the Corvette are you a
middle-aged American man like me who
never got married and doesn't have kids
so now for son that's what ends up
that's one end that's when that car
starts appealing to you yeah I start to
start thinking that [ __ ] you know maybe
I'll maybe I'll get myself a Corvette
maybe I'll go hang out on an Applebee's
and start hitting on somebody who's at
least [ __ ] born three decades after
me no I [ __ ] love Corvettes I think
they're there I just love to look at the
car I think it's uh you know it's an
american-made car I think it's a great
value you know what I mean I think you
know they got a Corvette guys like
[ __ ] 200 miles an hour now granted I
know I know that ones like six figures
but you can get a Corvette can't you get
a Corvette for like 65 grand I mean I
know it's a shitload of money but uh you
know I realized halfway through this I
you know how much a Porsche coughs is it
Porsche or Porsche I don't even know how
to say it that's another car that I
[ __ ] love that uh that you know I
can't afford you know much money I'd
have to make a [ __ ] year to justice
blowen basically a house on a car house
money on a car house money granted and
in [ __ ] Arkansas somewhere but still
you don't I mean so anyways I think the
way to go is rather than [ __ ] going
out and spending all that [ __ ] money
on the car you just go rent one for a
day so one day I landed in [ __ ]
Burbank Airport and I'm driving by Hertz
rental car and what do I see I see a
[ __ ] yellow Corvette sitting there
I'm not into the yellow but it's still a
Corvette and I'm thinking you know one
of these dude why don't I just [ __ ]
rent one for one day
you know I'll rent one for one day
what's that gonna cost right 300 400
bucks
that's a fuckload of money but it's it's
way less than 70 grand 75 grand what the
[ __ ] why not rent one of those things
you know I'll take my girl out we'll go
for a cruise up in the [ __ ] Hollywood
Hills we'll tip it over we'll die just
like that [ __ ] dude in the 50s who
look like Fonzie but that's not him what
is his name Johnny was his name Johnny
wasn't every [ __ ] bad boy named
Johnny back then did you ever notice
that [ __ ] one of my favorite things to
watch is old like those old
black-and-white movies whenever that
they're doing movies about gangs you
know and it's always a bunch of white
actors and half of them are gay just
flaming homosexuals and they're trying
to act tough and it's [ __ ] hilarious
the way they flip up their collar and
they pull up their sleeves what the [ __ ]
that I watched the other day was one of
the worst [ __ ] movies ever saw in my
life was a Marlon Brando movie that one
where he's on the motorcycle and he
stops into the town if you wanna [ __ ]
do you ever get embarrassed for someone
like somebody's doing something so
douchey that you just feel yourself just
wanting to crawl underneath the [ __ ]
hotel bed and lay next to the dead
hooker that you didn't even realize was
there in on I mean there is a scene in
that movie where they are in this bar
and these two guys start talking in this
street slang and and the old bartender
just can't
keep up with it and they're going like
hey daddio
if I can't even do it it's so funny I'm
gonna I can't get embarrassed or even
trying to recreate it it's [ __ ]
horrific so uh the [ __ ] am I talking
about yeah I want to rent this goddamn
car right so I'll rent it for one day
write it for one day I'm gonna tell you
something right now
la during the day especially during
these hotter months it's [ __ ]
horrible
it's like living in a city that's right
outside of God's stove and and you know
that doesn't make sense or I was trying
to you know I was trying to say that the
joke I was trying to do is like you have
a heat up an oven sure we all have at
some point you tried to cook a [ __ ]
turkey Oh [ __ ] remind me I gotta tell
you about a great YouTube video no you
know what I'm gonna forget let me get
back to the stove thing Thanksgivings
coming up everybody I know I'm all over
the place I'm gonna [ __ ] finish
something Brando thing I'm gonna finish
this stove thing and I'm gonna get back
to the Corvette story but first I'm
gonna tell them I'm gonna take a little
break for the holidays
all right over here in America for all
you people overseas boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo that was supposed to be ladies
and gentlemen on all ships I see we have
we have a holiday over here called
Thanksgiving where we give thanks for
the fact that our founding fathers
committed genocide and gave us all this
beautiful land out here [ __ ] you that's
how the world works you know we will
come and you saw our cutlasses you know
that's how the world works Smash Mouth
football the black and blue division
that's how it [ __ ] works the Norris
um no it isn't I don't advocate that
[ __ ] but you know what what would it
happened but you know they got their
casinos we named a couple of golf
courses after him you ever notice that
[ __ ] that's what I like about white
people we [ __ ] slaughter people then
we name [ __ ] after him once we feel bad
we'll call this one wampa tuck this is
the Whomper tuck grocery store and this
is the last and the Mohican
all the sec um anyways Jesus Christ bill
yes so I saw this YouTube video
Thanksgivings coming up alright and one
of the big things is a man is you have
to know how to carve a goddamn turkey
okay and as much as all you [ __ ] guys
out there want to act like you know how
to carve a turkey most see a [ __ ]
don't but you're too afraid to ask
because you're worried that someone's
gonna question your sexuality because
that's what it's like to be a man
basically if you don't just somehow know
[ __ ] without ever having explained it to
you that evidently means that you you
you want to have sex with another man
that's that's the laws that I learned
growing up um so anyways there is a
[ __ ] youtube video out there that of
course I can't check because these [ __ ]
of charged me thirteen dollars every
[ __ ] and it expires every noon but
they're just go on go on to YouTube
right and just Google how to carve a
turkey there is a [ __ ] dude on there
man I'm telling you you it's it's
unbelievable the way he takes his bird
apart it's masterful okay and don't make
the mistake I made last year because I
carved the thing up perfectly but the
problem was my knives were a little bit
dull go get your knives professionally
sharpened this month okay and just eat
spaghetti until Thanksgiving so you
don't [ __ ] them up because I swear to
god I've tried with that little
sharpener that you get a lot of people
just take out that sharpener out of that
little knife thing they just go and
there's a you have to [ __ ] hold the
thing at a certain angle and you can
actually be making the thing duller if
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing trust me because I did it you know
I watched a couple of three stooges
things and I saw them I saw curly look I
can't even [ __ ] do it my [ __ ]
voice is so trashed anyways there's this
killer YouTube video man and it's like
literally when this guy is done with the
thing you got you got the drumsticks the
wings in the dark meat everything's
lined up like that and then you got all
the white meat with just a little bit of
skin on top of it lined up like a
[ __ ] deck of cards and you come out
with your serving tray I mean if people
faint it looks so good
that [ __ ] carcass is just it's
immaculate
alright so definitely check that
if you're gonna make a turkey and if
you're one of those people to who wants
to deep-fry a [ __ ] turkey make sure
you put the turkey in the deep fryer
first okay and then fill it up with
water so you know how much [ __ ] grease
to put in there evidently that's what
people do is they fill it all the way up
to the top and then they drop the bird
in there and then it overflows catches
flame lights their deck on fire and they
burn down their house and that's not
Thanksgiving
that's not even Halloween anyways let me
get bad no what if I gotta back up here
so anyways this [ __ ] podcast is a
mess - [ __ ] that God's oven this is I'm
talking about you ever heat up a [ __ ]
oven you know and then you're checking
on whatever you're cooking and rather
than opening it and letting the heat
come out and then looking down with your
face you open the door with your face
right there and you get that [ __ ]
heat furnace blast
that's what summer is like in LA in July
and August but I'm gonna tell you at
night it's absolutely gorgeous I'm
telling you you should do it at some
point you ever come out to LA [ __ ] the
Hollywood sign [ __ ] going on sunset [ __ ]
all that go up on Mulholland Drive and
drive through the hills late at night
and look at the valley and all it looks
like Christmas man it's amazing so
that's what I wanted to do I was gonna
get this [ __ ] car cruise around up
there and you know have a couple of
drinks wrap it around a tree run away
from the scene blame it on a minority
you know I'm [ __ ] with you
you know I was gonna have a good [ __ ]
time that's what I wanted to do so I
call these [ __ ] [ __ ] up it hurts
I call him up cuz I want to rent this
car that's gonna cost me 350 bucks I'm
gonna throw a [ __ ] iPod right in the
trash for one [ __ ] day [ __ ] taking
some s turns up there in the Hills right
so I call him up and I say yeah listen I
want to rent that Corvette you got at
the Burbank Airport and they go okay
first of all I had to [ __ ] get
through they're stupid they're stupid
whatever they the the the computer thing
and you know of course they have this
this automated voice and you can tell
the person to the voice over they told
her just smile when she did it it says
this is a de Tony she goes thank you for
calling her its rental car
you can actually get a better deal if
you go to hereit's dad can ye this big
stupid [ __ ] grin on her face and it
wasn't bugging me I actually enjoyed it
the first time through cuz I'm like I'm
gonna get a Corvette for one [ __ ] day
I'm gonna live the dream I'm gonna live
the [ __ ] dream I'm gonna live the
American [ __ ] dream before they
collapse the dollar and combine us with
[ __ ] Canada and Mexico and put a
microchip in the middle of our [ __ ]
forehead I'm gonna do it I'm gonna get
this goddamn Corvette right so you know
he wanna [ __ ] have a toothbrush
shoved up your ass press 1 if you wanna
[ __ ] do a cartwheel press 19 so
finally up you get up to 20 if you want
to make a reservation I [ __ ] hit that
button then it's then right again
cankiwi Gilley here he'll place xB date
right takes me like [ __ ] 20 minutes
right press or say [ __ ] right I'm going
through all that [ __ ] so finally I'm
just like screaming operator into the
phone right so finally I get someone and
I say you know listen I want to rent you
know saw this car a Corvette you had at
the Burbank Airport and goddammit I'd
like to rent it and they go okay let me
give you the number for the Hertz rental
car location and they can help you with
that sir and I said okay ma'am and she
gives it to me alright so I hang up and
what do I do I call the Hertz location
out in Burbank and what do I get again
that same computer smiley voice thank
you for calling her channel car Helbig
speaking right if you know the extension
of the person how the [ __ ] would I know
that
how would I know what [ __ ] extension
would like to have football players and
they have a Hall of Fame career and I
know [ __ ] Brett Favre is extension
for out of [ __ ] what I know that [ __ ] so
once again operator screaming into the
phone and I want to [ __ ] talk to a
goddamn person but of course I can't
talk to a person what are they doing the
entire time they keep steering me to the
internet basically
in not so many words that this would be
a whole [ __ ] lot easier if you just
went on the internet eh dad cam right
you could just help us eliminate more
[ __ ] jobs so we can eventually
replace all of you with [ __ ] robots
you know so I'm like [ __ ] this I want to
talk to a goddamn person so finally I
get to the stupid you know all I get is
if you want to leave a message
you know I'm like I don't want to leave
a message all right and then they go
well you didn't you know they come on I
didn't make a decision I have to make a
[ __ ] decision I did make a decision
my decision is I don't like any
decisions you [ __ ] gave me to make so
I think if you want more teens base for
smiley face so I press four and then
basically if I wanted to talk to a
person I could basically schedule a
phone call when they could call me back
I could leave my phone number or I could
wait a half an hour so I hang up and I'm
like you know what I've just wasted a
half hour of my [ __ ] life so I call
these [ __ ] [ __ ] back again at the
National thing thank you for calling
here to yell car I'm back in that [ __ ]
again and I'm screaming operator to the
phone and I get somebody and say listen
who do I talk to to make a complaint
because at this point I'm like I'm not
renting this [ __ ] car from there I
know there's other places where I could
they they they rent these exotic cars as
they call them that I would like [ __ ] it
I'm just gonna go through them but I'm
but I'm gonna make sure that I complain
to somebody okay and I'm not going on
the internet and sending a [ __ ] email
right so I actually get a person and
they go okay well let me trance
okay I'm gonna transfer you I'm sorry to
hear that sir I'm very sorry to hear
that sir let me transfer you to our
complaints department I go okay thank
you she clicks it over dude thank you
for calling huge manager [ __ ] back in
it again right and they and they just
[ __ ] tell me if I if I'd like I can't
get I can't get to a [ __ ] person so
now I'm determined I'm gonna get to
somebody I call back again ganky
beginning here it's go through that
operator go to the [ __ ] again I get
to someone I say listen
okay you sitting down person on the
other side of the phone I would like to
make a complaint I don't want to fill
out a form I don't want to make an email
I want to talk to a person I do not want
to be transferred into your National
giggling Hertz [ __ ] thing again I
didn't say [ __ ] cuz it could've hung up
on me national system again I would like
to be transferred directly to a person I
believe you call it a warm transfer in
the creepy corporate world so can you do
a warm transfer meaning something alive
to something else alive they can
communicate with me she cuz yes sir I'm
sorry I'm sorry having this difficulty
I'd say I understand lady I understand
you're not on the yacht you're not on
the yacht you're on the dock getting
screamed at by guys like me every day
that's why I'm not yelling at you
alright
fucking's I'm on hold again she can't
get to be anybody then I go back to her
and then she hits me with the form what
is your name sir what an ad none of your
[ __ ] business
you don't need to know my name what do
you need to know my name for so you can
stick me on the hostile caller list
because I had the audacity to complain
about your kunti [ __ ] system I'm not
giving you my [ __ ] name I want to
talk to a person okay sir I just you
know I just
okay just following protocol I
understand that ma'am I'm not mad at you
I didn't see that contouring that [ __ ]
stuff that's what I was thinking but I
kept my goddamn cool I kept my cool just
like [ __ ] Steve McQueen and that
movie where he eats the deviled eggs
eggs so anyways I [ __ ] I [ __ ]
finally get to a person alright and I
just say really calmly
I just say look you know I've been on
the phone for 40 minutes trying to give
you guys 350 bucks okay and for the life
of me I can't do it because I keep
talking to computers and they keep
setting me back into your national
system now ma'am I know you have nothing
to do with this alright but I want to
know what is the best way that I can try
to complain so I can get to the inner
hive the inner layer of the hive here
and actually get to that that person
who's sitting there in those loafers
without any socks on sunning himself on
the deck of his yacht I want to get to
that guy the guy who made this policy
okay I like talking to people ma'am I
enjoy the fact that you still have a job
okay that's what I that's what I like
here my phone buzzing and my phone
buzzing hang on one second hey Paul let
me call you right back
I so you know what it actually worked so
basically what they did was is I got an
email and they go you can send an email
and I go and let me guess no one's gonna
call me right
someone's gonna email me back and act
like it's the actual friggin person that
I'm talking to but really it's gonna be
an intern who's being you know who's
working there for free and also part
time reads those books for Oprah's Book
Club so she can come on TV and acts like
she [ __ ] reads a foreign a page book
every [ __ ] week right is that are you
gonna give me two because if that's what
the deal is I want somebody up high so
basically they gave me allegedly the
email of the vice president at Hertz
reservations dad cam and I actually have
the guy's name now whether this is true
or not
I don't know but what I want to tell the
guy is that I was trying to [ __ ] rent
that [ __ ] flamin yellow Corvette that
they have out there in Burbank
California for the life of me I couldn't
do it and now I don't want to do it and
I'm gonna bring my business somewhere
else and I would appreciate it if you
know just hope against hope then maybe
you'd give some human being some jobs
because my experience with your company
is you may be at best have six people
[ __ ] working there because you just
you just keep trying to steer the herd
onto the internet and all you dumb [ __ ]
out there who are just constantly
helping them to get rid of people's jobs
you're out of your [ __ ] mind because
those people are gonna need jobs and
eventually they're gonna be willing to
do your [ __ ] job for a lot less
[ __ ] pay and considering we've sent
90% of our factories out of this [ __ ]
country now so now the American worker
is gonna have to [ __ ] compete with
sweatshop labor to make some [ __ ]
track shoes you know why don't we try to
keep the jobs
we have I'm not going to hurts calm you
try to pay me off with better rates go
[ __ ] yourself but some [ __ ] human
beings in there the way you used to and
you know what you'd be $350 [ __ ] rich
or I'd be driving a Corvette and
everybody would be [ __ ] happier you
could put some new varnish on your deck
of your [ __ ] boat you [ __ ]
[ __ ] so whatever I know there's got
to be a private place out there in LA
that I can call right up and they'll
probably charge me even more money and
you know what I don't give a [ __ ]
because I'm gonna go in there they'll
probably give me a little piece of
champagne or rut give me a [ __ ] foot
massage all right they probably won't do
that but I'll talk to a person and
that's what the [ __ ] I want that's all I
want a little [ __ ] human interaction
is asking too goddamn much all right so
anyway so there's that story all right
and I might tell you another story I
want to tell you guys some stories this
week all right why don't you put your
pajamas on all right get a fire going in
your [ __ ] apartment if they haven't
boarded the thing up because they're
worried about getting sued
wasn't that great back in the day where
if you started a fire was your [ __ ]
fault as opposed to the landlord's as
opposed to well why did you have a
fireplace in there well they had a
fireplace in there in case it got
[ __ ] cold out or maybe you want to
have a romantic evening with your girl
and you wanted to light a [ __ ] fire
that's why there's a fireplace in there
it's a fireplace it is a place for a
fire now if somehow you burned down the
[ __ ] apartment evidently you didn't
understand what place to put the [ __ ]
fire in you dumb [ __ ] who doesn't know
how to use a fireplace evidently there's
enough [ __ ] people so they need to be
boarded up boarding up a fireplace Jesus
Christ why don't you put Santa Claus in
jail while you're at it all right that
was a little big okay I'm just saying
you know I like fireplaces I like a
crack of the fire I don't like those
[ __ ] gas ones those fake fires I mean
technically it is a fire you know I
don't know what am I talking about let
me tell you a fantastic [ __ ] story
last night all right so I'm working the
road with Joe DeRosa young Joe DeRosa
the [ __ ] teen idol from the Opie and
Anthony show who is actually going to be
on the cover of teen beat this this
month
and it's actually I saw a little bit of
the photoshoot he's doing a tribute to
Annette Funicello and that other [ __ ]
guy was at Tony Curtis who the [ __ ] she
used to make those Beach movies with
whatever Joe's gonna be their shirtless
holding a surfboard and not he's never
looked sexier so uh the [ __ ] am I
talking about aye aye Christ I don't
even know anymore yeah so we go out last
night right we're doing the show is
these two big titted [ __ ] sitting in
the front [ __ ] row all right so we're
like oh wow look at these girls these
girls will probably be fun right and I'm
in a relationship but you know I like
being the wingman you know I love being
the wingman I'd love it I love talking
[ __ ] to girls I love hitting on girls I
[ __ ] do it all the time and then I
try to pawn them off to whoever the [ __ ]
I am and you know so I don't have any
goddamn guilt you know so anyway so long
story short we're talking to these
broads and it's clear that there's some
sort of strippers I don't know what the
[ __ ] deal is okay so we meet
everybody from whatever I'm gonna stop
naming names here okay so a huge group
of us from the show from the crowd and
everything we go we head out to this bar
right so one of the strippers is cool
the other one has a voice that could
literally crack a flat-screen TV all
right so the cool one shows up first she
sits down I'm like eh are you doing you
know I like at the end of the week I
hang out I'll buy a round for some
people you know I'm in a great mood I
had a good time I'm on my way home
you know I'll buy some people some
drinks so I say to her hey what would
you like to drink she's like I'll have a
[ __ ] gag at Google one of those
[ __ ] chick drinks so you know so I
get her a drink I buy young Joe DeRosa
[ __ ] drink right everybody's having a
good time and then this other person
shows up who I knew and she was a real
nice person I said hey what do you want
for a drink and she was like I'll get a
vodka redbull right I got my 20 dollar
bill out and then the strippers like
yeah make it two right and I was like
wait what
make it - you haven't even finished your
first trick don't be warding off my
money you finished your first one there
young lady
alright stand the [ __ ] down you're not
working right now not some [ __ ]
getting a [ __ ] lap dance all right
finish your [ __ ] milk and cookies
first so needless to say the
conversation cooled between the two of
us but I didn't give a [ __ ] man I was
having a good time but whatever it was
still kind of you know whatever talking
[ __ ] we were talking sports the
bartender was cool you know everything
everything was going great so we're
chilling out and all of a sudden this
[ __ ] the other [ __ ] stripper girl
shows up I was so [ __ ] it was just
such classic female [ __ ] she's got a
tits hanging out she's got the fuck-me
pumps on and she comes up she goes hey
and she sees a friend with a drink and
she knows goddamn well she didn't pay
for it so she looks over at me and
lessons like well that must have been
the SAP who [ __ ] bought it right so
she looks at me she goes hey Bill she's
like she's like what are you drinking
right and I know what she's doing I'm
like I'm drinking one of those Sam Adams
Oktoberfest and he's leaving like that
nice and awkward right cuz I know what
she's trying to get a drink out of me
right so she doesn't know what to do
she's like is it good I'm like why yes
yes it is at this point DeRosa knows
what's going on I don't know that he
knows what's going on so she looks at me
like okay well evidently he's not buying
any more drinks and then she looks at
Joe she's like hey Joe what are you
drinking and Joe gets his shit-eating
grin on his face
he goes why I'm drinking a Bud Light why
would you like to buy me one and she
didn't know what the [ __ ] to do she's
like uh yeah I guess he goes you know
what I think you should buy me a Bud
Light and you should buy my good friend
Bill Bar here another Oktoberfest what
do you think about that and at that
point I'm [ __ ] dying laughing the
other stripper girl next to me she's
laughing her ass off because she knows
what happened and then the [ __ ] girl
with the screechy voice is sitting
she doesn't know what the [ __ ] to do we
[ __ ] nailed in the way and then like
she's going she didn't know what to do
and Joe's just going yes why don't you
pay it forward for all the drinks that
guys have bought in you and that you've
drank and then immediately turned around
and [ __ ] walked away why don't you
for once buy a goddamn buy a couple of
drinks for a couple of guys and she's
like I in since you put it that way fine
I will I will I'm buying you a [ __ ]
drink and Joe's like how about some
shots too and she just was I don't know
what her [ __ ] ego was that she goes
fine I'll [ __ ] do that too so we
actually got a stripper to buy his two
bears and two shots so we're feeling
like the kings of the world and then all
of a sudden we found out from this
waitress that on the slide she tried to
put it on her boyfriend's [ __ ] credit
card what a scumbag right so we bust her
and we all we and when this big
commotion breaks out right before the
[ __ ] bartenders are about ready to
swipe the boyfriend's credit card we
were like Joe Joe Joe it right just like
an officer and a gentleman I got nowhere
else to go right we get him to stop and
they take out her ATM and she had to
[ __ ] pay for it and it was a done
deal
we had two drinks two shots from that
[ __ ] person who knows never paid for
a drink since she got her [ __ ] tits
right and this was the best part the
second we got our drinks we said thanks
a lot and we both got up and we walked
away I was tremendous tremendous it was
the best night ever and I'm just
standing that drink of my drink like 20
minutes later I'm milking it for all
it's worth this free [ __ ] beer that a
stripper bought me it was awesome right
and Joe's talking to some girl across
the way and he looking at us and I just
yelled over I go Joe he looks over me
and I did I did the Robert DeNiro line
from when he was eating at Joe Pesci's
mom right before they hacked up Billy
batts right he looked so he's like
what's up and I just pointed at the beer
the stripper had bought and I just went
delicious delicious and that was my
evening and that there's another story
for you would it be 35 minutes in you
got any more stories as a matter of fact
I do what else did I do this [ __ ]
weekend oh I know I took a trip to the
bull what is the Cotton Bowl bill while
Cotton Bowl is a stadium that's been
around I believe since the 20s and it's
the first place that the Dallas Cowboys
played in and the Dallas Texans in the
old AFL and goddamn it I found out it
still existed so I wanted to go [ __ ]
take a look at it so I went down there
and lo and behold they were having
there's Texas there Dallas Texas state
[ __ ] fair that they have every
goddamn year I got a new text message I
hear my little 16 year old phone call me
when you wake up I want to please you
[ __ ]
anyways so I go to take a tour of this
thing I miss the first place Tom Landry
coached the you know first season of the
Dallas Cowboys right the catalysis Cal
boys team that I loved which was
basically the Tom Landry years and I
never got into the Jimmie Johnson ones
because watching Tom Landry leave I mean
it was like watching Johnny Carson go
you know no disrespect to the next
people it's just it's just not Johnny
it's not Tom Landry you know I'm saying
so I never got into them so like this
you know is a big deal to go check this
out so I go to you know go to this tour
and was the worst [ __ ] tour ever took
in my life
it wasn't bad was an awesome tour but
just the lady was cute but she just
didn't [ __ ] know anything about the
stadium she goes as you can see on
either side they added some seats they
added seats all that shiny silver ones
those are the new ones and I was like
how many how many people the place is
[ __ ] huge agai people's this place
hold she's like I think like 23,000
23,000 I know you guys aren't into
sports the way I am 23,000 is like a
little hockey arena you know you have a
hockey game you sell out a hockey game
23,000 this is where [ __ ] Texas
Longhorns in the [ __ ] Oklahoma
Sooners play alright College stadiums do
not hold 23,000 at the Division one
[ __ ] level especially Texas Oklahoma
you know what I mean so I'm like I think
it's a little more I guess like 45,000 I
didn't [ __ ] know and she looks and she
goes you know I think it's 23,000 then
she looked in a little pamphlet she goes
I'm sorry it's 97 thousand
and I gotta tell you right now right
there
this stadium tour is [ __ ] over it's
over I don't want to hear another word
from you because that is the first fight
if you're doing a tour of a stadium like
if you were in the family feud and the
end the first question was you know
you're standing there with one arm
behind your back so you can't cheat I
don't understand why you have to do that
on the family feud right like what if
you lunge with two hands you're quicker
diving in like [ __ ] Petros anyway so
if the question was you know you've
taken a tour of the stadium what's the
first question you're gonna ask and you
[ __ ] slam your hand down the first
thing you would say is how many people
does this stadium hold how many people
does this stadium home [ __ ] number
one answer that's what it would be this
just chick acted like I asked her what
the [ __ ] consistency of the concrete
was four of the stadium she had no
[ __ ] idea and then she tried to say
that that back in the day the Cotton
Bowl the Cotton Bowl bo WL like a cereal
bowl it was open-ended on both sides
think about that for a second a stadium
that's called to be ever seen the Rose
Bowl the Rose Bowl isn't open on in
either side is it no it's shaped like a
[ __ ] bowl
she tried to say that the Cotton Bowl
was open on both ends for a while and
just in 2002 they closed it off what
they actually did was they put an upper
deck and as far as I could tell they
knocked down the endzone lower level and
they just they rebuilt that and they put
an upper deck but she was trying to say
that it was open-ended until 2002 and in
my head I'm going I don't think that
that's right I don't think that that's
right either and then we went into the
media room and lo and behold they have a
picture of the Cotton Bowl in 1958 and
closed you know I you know and it just I
don't know but we got to go down stand
right down near the field come right
down where all the players came out and
you know was asked me Len Dawson Hank
Stram Bob Lilley Chuck Holly you know
all that [ __ ] right up till now all the
modern day players Ricky Williams played
there
who else played on the Longhorn so many
[ __ ] guys that guy Vince Young all
those [ __ ] dudes I don't know Billy
Sims Earl Campbell you know it was a
[ __ ] great time then I walked out of
there and they and I went I walked
around their little State Fair isn't a
little State Fair it's actually a big
State Fair that they have and evidently
down here in Texas what they do is and
you people overseas who hate on
Americans are gonna love this [ __ ]
this is classic here what they do down
here in Texas is every year they fry
some every year we fry something
different last year was Oreos year
before that it was Twinkies we fried
coke one year fried pizza I'm not even
lying they fried all of this [ __ ] some
he told me they fried coca-cola I don't
how the [ __ ] you do that but they said
they did it I don't know how to do it
what do you freeze the coke huh and then
[ __ ] rolling around in some fly I
don't I have no [ __ ] idea but all I
know you know what evidently they're out
of [ __ ] ideas because this year you
know what they were frying they were
frying butter I swear to god they were
selling fried [ __ ] butter and I'm
like you that is the most disgusting
[ __ ] thing I have ever heard in my
life god damn it I have to try it I
gotta try it I have to see what it is
like I made a little [ __ ] youtube
video actually I gotta have the kid I
was with made a little video of me
trying that little delicacy that little
Texas delicacy dude it was the most
disgusting [ __ ] thing I ever had I've
asked the guy say all right well first
thing I want to do was get the fried
Oreo cuz evidently that was a big hit
that kind of made sense to me fried Oreo
is [ __ ] up as that is I would figure
because it's fried it's gonna be salty
but then you got the sugary cookie to
kind of offset the - you know it's kind
of like you know you did some lines and
now you drinking some alcohol - even
yourself out same [ __ ] thing just in
a food way right so I went over to that
one first and I go yeah let me get in
the guy's like I dunno I'm like yeah let
me get one of those fried Oreos Oreo
cookies and he goes aw I'm sorry we
can't we can't cook yet until the health
inspector
comes up and and gives us the okay the
Elton's health inspector has to inspect
our booth first so my next logical
question was like well how do you think
you're gonna do I know hopped into a
restaurant like hang on a second I'd
love to have a give sandwich let's just
have the health inspector go through
first let's just see we have an
acceptable amount of roaches
so I said [ __ ] I went straight to the
fried butter and evidently they had
already been inspected and I said all
right I know how can I help you I go I
gotta get some of that fried butter the
guy goes alright what do you want you
want original you want something else
too something else I go let me get the
original and he goes all right and he
goes oh yes he said but did your choice
of toppings I forget what the [ __ ] they
were but I went with the Welch's grape
jelly I know this is disgust think you
know what's funny is probably there's
somebody working out on a treadmill
right now listening to this feeling a
lot better about themselves so they
basically they look like these little
you know Duncan munchkins with donut
holes that's what it looked like and
then there was like the grape jelly
there was there was the the grape jelly
sorry my phone keeps ringing
so I dip it in the grape jelly and I
took a bite out of it and dude it was
the most disgusting [ __ ] thing I've
ever tasted in my life it tasted like a
flavorless doughnut and then you know
that awful gum that has the squirting
inside that was like the inside except
it was butter it was just a little
nugget of like butter it was [ __ ]
gross and it was so disgusting I had to
have another one because you know what
you know one for each of ventricle
ventricles you got if you got more than
two maybe that's why I'm still [ __ ]
living I don't know what but I had
another one just to be like is was it
that bad and yes it was it was it was
wrong was just that's all I can say I
was just [ __ ] wrong and should not be
done and yeah I'm just gonna leave at
that I think we end the podcast right
here cuz I'm out of stories and Jesus
Christ my [ __ ] phone once I got it I
have a voicemail I'm going to New York
next week
I'm gonna get my blackberry I'm gonna
get a new BlackBerry again I didn't get
one out in LA cuz if you do it out in LA
they can't give you a New York number
you know I want to keep that number just
because at this point I've had the
number forever you know I don't have to
call [ __ ] 9,000 people I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about all
right this has been the Monday morning
podcast I apologize I didn't have any I
don't have any questions this week did I
I don't have anything because I couldn't
get to my email I had a couple this is
September 24th alright I'm going to read
one here this is actually commenting on
rugby and women all right here we go
bill after hearing your show this week
regarding rugby where you asked whether
or not any rugby player has played in
the NFL I decided to do some research on
the subject what I found out is that
there have been several rugby players
who've crossed over to play in the NFL
many of their names won't ring a bell
because it appears they are all kickers
and punters the two names that came up
the most often were Ben Graham a kicker
who I think played for the Jets and Mick
Luck Hurst was also a kicker who played
for the Falcons from 1981 to 1987 what I
found funny was that the rugby guys who
attempted to try out for other positions
such as linebacker or running back or
often considered too small too slow or
too weak to do damage on the field
against the much larger NFL players now
I know a lot of people in England are
gonna flip out about that [ __ ] well you
know what they say that all the time
that American football players are a
bunch of [ __ ] because they wear
helmets and all that type of [ __ ] well I
Got News for you there's a great article
in GQ magazine that I actually read now
I never read GQ because it's kind of
like the male Cosmo where you just open
it up and there's a ton of articles not
articles there's a ton of advertising
you can't find where the [ __ ]
articles are and it smells like Cologne
I swear to god it does it's really a
[ __ ] it's a really awful magazine but
I got to tell you this there was there's
a woman on the cover of this magazine
Olivia Wilde might be the most beautiful
woman I've ever seen in my life she's
just ridiculous and I was like I have to
read this article about this this this
female and it turned out there was an
article in there about concussions and
above football players going crazy and
killing themselves professional football
players and they were talking about Mike
Webster the center for the Pittsburgh
Steelers it's an unbelievable article
it's a Olivia Wilde is on the cover and
basically they were saying the helmets
because that's the number one thing I
hear these English guys can saying that
you know American football players are
[ __ ] because they they weigh like the
helmets and the pads evidently that all
the helmet does is it protects the skull
it doesn't protect the brain because the
brain sits in like fluid and and moves
around so when you get slammed in the
side of the head and not only mentioned
they were saying the way they build
these helmets is back when they had
leather helmets you know back in the
days the Three Stooges days if you watch
the guys play football they didn't lead
with their heads because you get knocked
out but now in an effort to protect the
heads they were basically saying what
they've done with these helmets is they
created a weapon and these football
players especially the linemen every
play if you watch them they just slam
into each other with their heads and I
evidently they're doing unbelievable
amounts of brain damage and Mike
Webster's brain he basically he went
crazy and he couldn't [ __ ] remember
[ __ ] so they during the autopsy they
removed his brain they sliced it in half
and he had list Alzheimer I don't know
this plaque I don't know what they
called it but it was like they said it
should have been the brain of like an 89
or 90 year old guy and this guy died at
50 so I'm not saying that rugby guys are
[ __ ] or anything like that I was just
giving people [ __ ] or whatever but I'm
just defending American football players
saying that you know just because they
have that [ __ ] helmet on you know
what I mean I find that really
interesting like is I used to always
watch guys riding motorcycles Mike dude
you out of your [ __ ] mind do you
realize the brain damage you're gonna
get if your head slams off a curb like
Gary Busey did and evidently obviously
you know if you're wearing a hell
you know you're protecting you know from
literally putting a hole in your head so
you should wear it but you know I'd
never really dawned on me obviously
because I'm a comedian and not a [ __ ]
neurosurgeon that'd just be you can have
a helmet on and your brain can you can
have just as much I think basically just
as much brain damage I think what you
would have to have is some sort of like
hard shell in the middle and then like
80 feet of nerf on the outside of our
spongy [ __ ] material on the outside
so we would have to start to slow your
head down before it came to that to the
what am I trying to say I think beyond a
certain speed it doesn't make a
difference whether you have a [ __ ]
helmet on or not because your brain is
gonna slam against the inside of your
skull so [ __ ] hard that is not gonna
matter and there you go that's coming
from a comedian so you know it's it's
medically accurate all right let's move
on here um and once again to those
people I have no disrespect eyes are
[ __ ] tough sons of [ __ ] I have no
but no no questions about that but you
really have to stop saying that American
football players are [ __ ] because
they have pads on those [ __ ] guys you
know you wouldn't want to play rugby
against them put it that way all right
all right let's plow ahead here all
right bill
you also stated some some ways you can
tell when you've won an argument with
the one stuff like the crying and when
they begin to switch your words to talk
about past topics in the middle of an
argument yeah they bring up other [ __ ]
that you did because they're losing the
[ __ ] that you're talking about right
then and there I guess guys do that too
but anyways let's plow ahead here he
said well I have a better one on my way
to work my wife and I were arguing over
me hurting her feelings because I came
home from a 10-hour day at work and
three and a half hours of night school
just wanting to go to bed so even though
my sexy Latin woman wasn't it was was
ready for some action I simply took a
shower crawled into bed next to her and
went to sleep
needless to say she was pissed so this
morning we were fussing about it and she
says that really hurt my feelings
because it felt like you didn't want me
and he said
and I don't know what what came over me
but instead of being an angry black man
I simply smiled grabbed grabbed her hand
kissed it and calmly said in a soft
voice now you know how I felt last week
and she said absolutely nothing she just
stared at me like she wanted to start
the waterworks but she couldn't get
a-goin I dropped her off at the office
where she kissed me and actually
apologized I smiled the entire way to
work Wow
I actually thought she was gonna get mad
because that was kind of harsh the way
you said it
that's like stand-up applause break
stand-up comedy well now you know I felt
last week yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that's how I
would have delivered it but I guess you
said it nice and calmly but yeah you
know that is kind of [ __ ] up that's
one of the things that I have found like
in a relationship is you know you got to
watch out because for the most I think I
would I would venture to guess without
doing a survey as always I would venture
to guess that 92% of relationships women
control the sex because guys will do it
basically whenever I really sound like a
hacky comedian guys we don't give a [ __ ]
but it seriously and then women kind of
use it as a they start using yeah he's
still been about that as a reward you
took out the trash here a good boy and
you get like a [ __ ] you know you
can't do that if you really want to
equalize you know the whole sex in your
relationship you why you got it you got
to continue to rub one out every once in
a while so that way you know if they
don't want to have sex and you're like
alright that's cool you know and then
yeah keep it keep adding any then you
create no war because I would say then
what you do was next time they want to
have it then you act like you don't have
it that's not the way to go about doing
it cuz then you start playing games with
each other what you probably should say
is I don't just basically what I've said
to women which is oh yeah bill we should
say exactly what you said cuz you have
your [ __ ] life figured out your
[ __ ] single four-year-old psychopath
yeah once again I want to say don't ever
listen to what I say on here you know I
am NOT a trained person and I'm worried
at some point someone's gonna take my
advice they're gonna get punched in the
face and I'm gonna get sued so you got
to understand that you're talking to a
comedian here who's maybe read three
book
in his life two of them had pictures on
every other page all right that's that's
what you're dealing with no way she
should I'm telling you the big thing
with women is if you want to get your
way is not to get mad not to play a
[ __ ] game with them you just have to
tell them how what they're doing is
making you feel they can't get around it
if you have a legitimate complaint you
know I mean I got something ridiculous
like hey I want to put in your ass and
you won't let me and it's really making
me feel like you don't trust me I mean
that's I think you're gonna lose that
one all right but um let's try to get
back on track here if you [ __ ] you
know like some serious like that we just
like look you know I feel like any time
you want to have sex I'm willing but
there's a lot of times I want to have it
and you don't want to have it and now so
now I kind of feel like this thing that
we're allegedly sharing together you you
totally control and that doesn't make me
happy thoughts
whatever you probably the [ __ ] you said
you say it calmly without saying [ __ ]
and I'm telling you well what can they
do
they gotta sit there and answer it and I
can guarantee you that Oh that'll work
out good for you for at least three
[ __ ] days before it slides back to
normal again it's a never-ending fight
alright but what you got to do is you
got to have the fights you got to have
the fights and protect your real estate
or you gonna spend you're gonna spend
your entire time and goal-line [ __ ] D
that's the worst [ __ ] relationship -
you've given up so many [ __ ] the
whole time its fourth and goal first and
goal what am I talking about first and
[ __ ] goal alright you just jumped
offside so it's half the distance to the
[ __ ] go we got it bill
you're in a bad situation alright that's
all I'm saying okay that's the end of
the podcast thank you everybody for
listening alright here's what I got
coming up I'm gonna be at the stress
factory in New Brunswick New Jersey
coming up this Friday Saturday and
Sunday well what are the dates bill well
why don't you hold on a second and I'll
get them for you God knows I can't go on
the [ __ ] Internet that's gonna be
Friday October 2nd
oh my god where's this year going
Saturday October 3rd and Sunday October
4th I am going to be at the stress
factory in New Brunswick New Jersey fans
of the Opie and Anthony and little
jiminy jiminy radio program I'm going to
be on there on Friday September 2nd and
I believe Monday I miss off Friday
October 2nd and I believe Monday October
5th those two days I am going to be in
studio with my best friends of all time
in radio the Opie and Anthony show
really excited to see them sons of
[ __ ] again and after that I am going
to be at the improv in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania on October 8th October 9th
and October 10th and I will be with
Randy Bowman on dve for all you
Pittsburgh people I will be on the
morning radio program on October 7th 8th
and 9th so please listen and and that is
it I appreciate all you guys listening
to my podcast I apologize that I had to
put this one up on Tuesday but I'm
fighting the man man all right I'm
[ __ ] with you you guys all have a
good week bless all you take it easy
[Music]
hi Paul
Oh
[Music]